the three top of excellent and there was
a surprisingly rich period for event are
the Camp David of submit of 78 and them
are a low and the egyptian-israeli
Treaty of March of that year which
Americans broke it all the way through
the Iranian Revolution which is
obviously critical for everything that's
happened since which culminated with the
departure of the shower in January 1979
and the the two as it basically was in
Afghanistan in 1978 which led eventually
to the Soviet intervention at the end of
79 so we're dealing with the legacy of
all of those events now Iraq was brought
into the play the Saddam Hussein made
himself president in the summer of 79 in
part because of the need for a response
to the Iranian resolution is already the
regime's strong man they were after the
american embassy siege seizure in
november though 79 there was an event in
in pakistan and saudi arabia which sort
of added to the sense of drama and
radicalized those countries as well so
all sorts of things followed from from
those events it was just one of those
times with a number of different strands
come together to produce a rather
explosive combination
I mean a number to construct me about
the Carter presidency MacArthur himself
obviously a thoroughly decent sort of
guy hadn't really before dealt with
issues of this sort in this sort of way
and I think the engineering him was
always believing that there was a
rational way through also I think that
struck me about Carter which worked with
some people were not with others was a
very personal approach so if he got on
with people and thought they were
responding well to him he was likely to
do more for them that if he found them
sort of cold and indifferent and this
was vaguely petulant quality that came
into that as well the other thing that
struck me not at all original was that
the different strands in his thinking
his own thinking were represented by
different players in the administration
so big rosinski who's a national
security adviser some of those on one
shoulder as the hawk and sciences the
Secretary of State was on another
shoulder as the dev and Carter never
wholly reconciled this tension and I
think that meant that when you were
faced with a fast-moving event like like
Iran it worked pretty poorly and then
when you're working with a trying to
just to work your way through a knotty
problem like Egyptian Israeli relations
it didn't work that badly at all because
you could be patient and try to put the
bits together but with something fast
moving like Iran and Afghanistan I think
the lack of underlying harmony the
ability to resolve these tensions
produced a pretty confused policy on the
other hand the policy was going to be to
try to do what was best for the Shah of
Iran at least during 78 and as the show
himself didn't really know what he
wanted and was vacillating it was hard
for the Americans to make up his mind
for him so I think Carter gets an unfair
rap in some ways
because people remember the vacillation
in other respects the Americans didn't
really look deep enough at the regime
and its vulnerabilities and therefore
allow themselves to get caught by
surprise well I think Carter in the
south in seven pieces president first
developed a very warm relationship with
Sadat was seen to be a particular
unusually pro Arab American president
and while he would say that that was not
the same as being anti-israeli to
summarise and that's how it came over in
the US and he certainly he didn't he
didn't like the Israeli leaders he had
to deal with as much as he likes so that
it didn't like rub in he liked begin
even less he said you know baking as
somebody who never gave me a pleasant
surprise one of the phrases he used
about him a man is carried through to
the present day as he with the book with
apartheid in the title which is the sort
of thing that is calculated to irritate
Israelis and in consequence please Arabs
so I think they saw him as a president
who was trying to get the best possible
solution and you know cart invested an
incredible amount of time on to this one
problem more than any other
international problem other than
possibly arms control and Russia know
that this is what he put the for exactly
you